Socialism,
Nazism,
progressivism,
isms
have done so much damage.
But people still believe in them.
Here is an outline
of all the systems of government.
Matt Kibbe
made this video about
the deadly isms.
At the bottom,
you'll see the worst types
of totalitarianism,
national socialism,
Marxism,
communism.
All of these far right isms involve a lot
of government control of the means of production.
On the far left,
you have Socialism,
and Marxism,
and Maoism.
All of these isms, we're told,
are fundamentally different
than those on the right.
But when you think about it,
they sort of feel the same.
You still have government control
of businesses and factories,
There's no freedom of speech,
there's no freedom of association,
there's hardly any freedom at all.
Pundits talk about these things
in terms of
right vs left.
This phony left right spectrum,
it creates two problems.
First of all,
it keeps us fighting with each other,
when we otherwise might find common values,
we might find common ground,
we might agree
on the rules that hold civil society together.
In truth, this whole left-right thing,
it's the wrong way
to think about political philosophy.
Now many Americans say,
I'm not left or right,
I'm in the middle.
I like
bi-partisanship.
Trouble is,
when Republicans and Democrats agree,
that usually means
they've agreed to spend
more of your money.
That's what the politicians mean when they say,
we're meeting in the middle.
This celebrated middle of the road
-- where Republicans collude with Democrats
to say,
bail out Wall Street,
this can't be where the good stuff comes from,
can it?
No,
most of the good stuff happens
outside politics.
It comes from millions of free people
working together,
voluntarily.
America has been spared totalitarism and the
other worst isms of the world.
Capitalism
is mostly good, because it's voluntary.
But
it's not if it's crony capitalism,
crapitalism,
corporatism.
Corporatism.
This is big business in cahoots with big government,
fixing prices,
raising costs,
screwing the competition.
This is pretty much where we
are today.
We got to big government corporatism
with the help of experts,
technocrats,
people who say,
we don't have any isms,
we just
want to do what works.
I am not an ideologue.
I'm not.
Technocratic progressivism like espoused
by Barack Obama and his cohorts
is still an ism.
We'll get to progressivism in this series.
Yes, this is a series
on different forms of government,
the isms of the left and the right,
but also the alternative.
We're going to talk about liberty.
We're going to talk about people cooperating.
We're going to talk about entrepreneurship,
and all of the really cool things that happen
when people are left free.
Kibbe's bottom line:
I'll be on your side
as long as you don't hurt people
and you don't take their stuff.
That's a political philosophy
to get behind.